quelques questions générales il ne nous
reste qu'une heure
je vais parler vite
très très vite c'est un bonjour tout le
monde je suis nathalie akhras nova je
suis blogueuse écrivain comique de stand
up vous pouvez m'appeler quand vous
voulez et aujourd'hui nous allons parler
de cyber harcèlement
nous n'y avons pas je m'appelle alia et
j'ai déjà 22 ans
quel cauchemar j'ai toute ma vie était
attiré par les choses créatives
j'ai envie d'être actrice de dessiner et
j'aime beaucoup me maquiller donc voilà
bientôt cnic lit je suis au triste de
livres et d'une formation pour apprendre
aux filles à s'aimer à construire des
relations harmonieuses
je suis mère de deux enfants et il ya
cinq ans j'ai décidé de devenir
blogueuse médicale aujourd'hui j'anime
un bloc qui est lu par plus de deux
millions de personnes
je suis blogueuse sociologues
psychologues en thérapie familiale et
écrivain j'anime des séminaires et des
webinaires avez-vous des eaters beaucoup
j'en ai depuis longtemps
[Musique]
épidémie le coronavirus prend notre
planète d'assaut à une souche m'a touché
et la voilà en personne et je les nommer
alia j'ai rencontré mon petit ami qui
est blogueur il voulait ma prendre tout
ce qu'il savait c'est comme ça que je
suis arrivé sur youtube dont j'ai
commencé à tourner et j'ai trouvé de
l'équipement je me suis fait une bonne
lumière
j'ai commencé à faire des vidéos pour
youtube ce qu'on appelle un blog beauté
maintenant car je me maquille je montre
des produits cosmétiques
j'en parle l'audience augmente tous les
jours j'ai de plus en plus d'abonnés et
mais j'ai des émetteurs ceci
inévitablement la société est
malheureusement de plus en plus
agressive ce ne sont pas des gens
spécifiques qu'ils communiquent sur
internet de telle ou telle manière
ce sont des gens ordinaires qui sont
épuisés de mauvaise humeur que la
pandémie est le coronavirus 30 furieux
et ça ne va certainement pas changer de
sitôt
j'avais mes nice mais il ya de ça
[Musique]
as tu des haters bah oui ça arrive il
faut regarder la caméra c'est ça oui oui
tu as des haters yoshi bien sûr beaucoup
en proportion beaucoup moins que de fans
et au moci gdgt heures la première fois
que j'ai lu toutes ces choses
désagréables sur moi sur internet ça a
d'abord été très dur mais je me suis dit
que je pourrais les faire changer d'avis
au début ils ont commencé à me critiquer
parce que je suis est enveloppé parce
que je suis en surpoids vive le poids
cette apparence qui ne correspond pas
aux standards aux canons de la société
rend toujours beaucoup de gens instable
et mal à l'aise
c'est comme s'il craignait que si
c'était autorisé dans la société sont
tout le monde ressemblerait tout de
suite à sa réponse navette ce paquet
millions nous prenons un peu de crème
anticellulite et mettons plus sur le
poulet la première fois que je fais face
à des agressions c'était lorsque j'ai eu
une soudaine croissance de nombre
d'abonnés après la création de ma ds
beauty si vous n'aimez pas vos chambres
nous pouvons les rendre plus minces un
peu plus mince c'est un personnage
étrange et incompréhensible
au fond c'est une nana stupide alors que
moi je suis docteur en sciences mère de
deux enfants est pas la pire mers du
monde
mais les lakers ont commencé à écrire
non mais regardez l'unc comme un wagon
elle aurait pu suivre un régime non vie
où sont les sens on voit tout de suite
que personne là elle se tape tout le
monde c'est sûr mais on peut dire que
chaque blogueur a une image celle qui
fait voir au public
il est mais il a aussi une vie hors
écran privé moyens afin de pas les
acteurs veulent intimider la personne à
cause de l'image qu'ils se font d'elle
la blogueuse se fait passer pour une
idiote et alors chez moi il n'y a que du
vin donc on va préparer une pizza à base
de vin
istres a touché l'os bush je viens de
sortir de la douche et pendant que mes
cheveux sèche je voulais répondre à une
question pourquoi je me connais si bien
en matière financière
ils étaient irrités par ma popularité
ils étaient irrités par mes succès
financier d'ailleurs par le fait que je
me charge d'enseigner quelque chose il
est héritée par mon apparence par ma
famille partout les moqueries sont
motivés par l'envié c'est une manière de
satisfaire son ego parce qu'on ne
possède pas ces choses là ces
commentaires sont souvent fait sous
forme de conseils amicaux
par exemple ces sources ils ne vont pas
vous avez besoin de changer de style où
ça peut être plus grossier beau les
agglos par exemple on m'a écrit vous
n'êtes pas en forme il faut que vous
alliez à la gym
certains disent non mais pourquoi ils
continuent de bouffer tout le temps et
si l arrêter de manger autant pas qui
est je me demande toujours ça vous
regarde autant également je ne mange pas
qu'est ce que ça peut vous faire
il y a une raison plus profonde qui
explique pourquoi later s'accroche à ça
il commence à harceler la personne ok ça
dérange la vie bien tranquille du hunter
film il s'inquiète parce que les canons
de beauté les normes esthétiques de la
société pourrait changer et il se dit
qu'il va devoir s'adapter et ressembler
à ça
dans notre pays beaucoup de gens pensent
que se maquiller et vulgaire que les
cheveux teints et la cosmétique sont
vulgaires ma grand mère est comme ça
[Musique]
nous sommes demandé pourquoi tant de
personnes ne font rien quand elles sont
témoins de cyber harcèlement quand elle
voit que quelqu'un est harcelé 13 %
avouent avoir peur que l'agression se
retourne contre eux outre manif samir de
10 57% sont persuadés qu'il est normal
de ne pas intervenir et de rester
observateur qu'il ne faut rien faire
avec date choisie samedi à touba 120 %
se sentent impuissants lorsqu'il voit
quelqu'un se faire intimider en ligne ça
veut tout d'abord dire que cela provoque
tout de même une réaction chez
l'observateur haut débit si elle éprouve
des émotions négatives en voyant que
quelqu'un d'autre se fait insulter
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment eu peur quand j'ai compris
qu'il ne se bornait pas à faire des
commentaires énervé sur le net par
exemple ils ont commencé à écrire des
lettres à tous mes annonceurs
oui mais quand il s'est avéré qu'il
savait à quelle heure mon mari arrivée
au travail en partie étant il allé en
voyage d'affaires bas
vieillot j'ai une certaine sur internet
passe aussi dans la vie réelle une telle
attention donne l'impression que
quelqu'un vous suit en permanence
qu'est-ce qu'il fait qu'est ce qu'il
regarde ton idole que va-t-il faire
ensuite on se sent sous surveillance en
permanence et on ne peut pas se
comporter naturellement on est en proie
à une anxiété permanent année dernière
nous avons étudié le nombre de personnes
victimes de harcèlement pour voir s'il y
avait des tendances
si cela les adolescents en été victime
mais non ce n'est pas le cas aussi les
hommes et les femmes adultes sont
souvent victimes d'agressions mais de
manière différente pour les femmes
l'harcèlement se focalise souvent sur
l'apparence à mushin les hommes sont
harcelés pour les petits manquements
quotidien par exemple s'ils n'ont pas
agi en homme dans une telle ou telle
situation
ça peut déclencher des vagues géantes
d'agression bonsoir à tout le monde
je vais commencer ce direct en
démystifiant l'idée de la personne qui
réussit toujours une solution
comme ça les autres une histoire
terrible une histoire horrible m'est
arrivé récemment nous avons organisé un
séminaire avec un psychologue la veille
du séminaire ce psychologue m'appelle et
me dit vicat je ne sais pas si je dois
participer à votre séminaire de demain
car j'ai reçu un appel d'un numéro
inconnu et on m'a dit que si j'étais
hystérique et que j'enseignais comme
vicat dimitrieva de mauvaises choses aux
parents dans mon enfant en souffrirait
yes demande là on touche le fond c'est
même pire on commence à menacer les en
face à brest histoire métier
ashok de toute évidence s'il a trouvé le
numéro de téléphone de l'expert et l'a
appelée ou s'il menace comme ça un
moment donné cela ne lui suffira plus il
passera à l'acte dans la vie réelle est
assez sérieux - vaches à lait nous
sommes allés voir des avocats des
enquêteurs je ne vais pas énumérer tous
ceux avec qui nous avons parlé
croyez-moi quand on menace votre enfant
s'il vous mettez tout sens dessus
dessous et ils ont tous dit la même
chose vous ne pouvez rien faire vous
pouvez mais cela n'amènera rien on ne
voit malheureusement sont fait d'une
telle manière qu'on ne traite que les
conséquences et quelles sont les
conséquences de propos insultants
c'est publié sur internet voilà tout je
crois que tout dans notre vie dépend de
l'estimé de soi tant cac et a des
relations que nous construisons l'homme
que nous laissons entrer dans notre vie
[Musique]
pire qu'on écrit ça a été quand mon père
est mort si on fait une publication à ce
sujet c'est qu'on veut se mettre en
avant
il faut garder le silence on réclame de
la compassion
on n'a pas de principes si on ne fait
pas de publications ou le cash on s'en
fout on est indifférent
je ne cherche qu'à faire des stories
donc on ne peut jamais agir comme il
faut il n'y a pas d'option ne serait pas
coupable les acteurs parlent souvent de
même il existe une théorie psychologique
selon laquelle lorsqu'une personne
exprime une opinion négative
elle ne fait en réalité que dire ce
qu'elle ferait elle même comment elle se
comporteraient pas mon genre je le pire
est que ce n'est pas moi qui ai reçu le
message mais ma soeur y souscrire elle
l'a lu quand j'étais avec elle j'ai vu
son visage blême up contre autrichien
comment elle a répondu et ont ensuite
bloqué tout le monde de court salut à
tous les amis chers citoyen chaque
citoyenne
cette année a été très difficile pour
nous nous avons eu beaucoup de riders
beaucoup de négativité beaucoup de don't
like et très peu de like donc pour cette
nouvelle année je souhaite à tous
mineurs enseignants médecins d'avoir
beaucoup de like
la pire chose que j'ai reçu c'est un
commentaire sous une vidéo
les blogueurs comme crasse nova il faut
les réunir et les brûler c'est un appel
direct à l'action je ne vois pas la
personne quelqu'un qui sait à quoi je
ressemble écrit je vais te tuer je ne
peux pas le voir
je ne sais pas s'il est sérieux si les
manades si vous êtes malade là comment
je peux le savoir je panique
[Musique]
l'étude de cette année montre 49% des
sondés ont remarqué une augmentation des
agressions
les gens perdent leur emploi tombe
maladie s'énerve à cause de toutes les
restrictions qui leur sont imposées
un homme on a tué un autre parce qu'ils
portaient un masque
alors que le premier était contre le
niveau d'agressivité et littéralement
surréaliste et ces gens là sont en ligne
et en ligne
on peut toujours trouver quelqu'un qui a
tort on trouvera toujours une opinion
avec laquelle on n'est pas d'accord
4 news c'est horrible mais le coc vie 19
s'est propagée non seulement dans les
poumons des ports chinois mais aussi
dans les cerveaux des russes loue
aujourd'hui notre expert en la matière
sera à ya vraiment mon copain et moi
avons décidé de faire une vidéo de
réaction à des marchandises qu'on trouve
sur un vito
hier des pommes pour guérir du coc vite
et d'autres virus produits du potager un
mur anti cancer alala anticancer des
pommes immunomodulatrice et yappa coach
je suis très timide
j'ai toujours la voix qui tremble
c'était une vidéo assez ordinaire où je
ne me suis pas vraiment mise en valeur
j'étais simplement à 6 devant la caméra
et je n'ai rien fait ou on y tient parce
que je n'ai fait que rigoler c'est tout
moi vos posts et les villes j'ai ri
devant la caméra
nous avons posté la vidéo mais beaucoup
de gens ont détesté ya sept ans j'étais
juste bon le fait d'exister pour avoir
parlé avec cette personne pour avoir été
dans la vidéo pour avoir décidé de
[Musique]
composer arrêté là en regardant ça je
m'inquiète pour rallier à ce qu'elle
décrit est la preuve la plus directe a
qu'une personne qui est victime de
harcèlement
que ce soit en ligne ou dans la vie on
n'a aucune raison de souffrir de
harcèlement
elle n'a rien à voir avec ça ce sont des
personnes réelles qui en sont
responsables
seul dahlia était juste devant la caméra
la première fois que j'ai vu les
commentaires
m
il y en a en fait la première fois que
j'ai lu les commentaires je me suis dit
qu'est ce que ces gens sont bêtes si peu
éduqués si mesquin au printemps mais
ensuite je ne sais pas comment c'est
arrivé mais je n'ai pas pu dormir
pendant les deux nuits qui ont suivi
j'ai juste pleuré dans mon oreiller un
tombeau
ça faisait vraiment mal parce que
j'étais une jeune blogueuse je n'étais
pas prête et toute cette négativité
s'est déversée sur moi honnêtement je ne
m'y attendais pas
[Musique]
vous savez ce qu'il y à de difficiles
aussi face à ces intimidations
c'est qu'on a honte d'en parler à
quelqu'un la plupart des victimes
d'intimidation sont gênés elles se
disent si j'étais quelqu'un de bien on
ne m'intimide rep ah si ça arrive ça
veut dire qu'il ya quelque chose que je
fais mal personne ne devrait ne pourrait
y être prêt il n'existe pas de
profession de ce type
sauf peut-être pour les militaires mais
ça implique une violence directe quand
j'ai commencé à communiquer avec le
public
ce n'était pas pour qu'on me tabac spicg
ra pas chaud si on décide de devenir une
personne publique il faut s'attendre à
de tels commentaires
le respect des limites personnelles y
est totalement absent par exemple je
vais en ligne je raconte un petit bout
de ma vie je décide exactement ce que je
veux raconter à mon sujet mais quand je
fais ça pour une raison quelconque une
personne va se dire que si j'ai partagé
cela elle a le droit de creuser plus
profondément de donner son avis sur ce
que j'ai dit de me conseiller sur ce que
je devrais dire ou écrire et de se
sentir offensés si je ne suis pas ses
conseils
écoutez en fait l'année 2020 c'est comme
avec mon ex
il y a eu bien sûr de bons moments mais
pourquoi vouloir vraiment et revenir je
ne suis pas encore complètement folle il
m'arrivait de disparaître tout
simplement pour une journée ou deux à
des moments comme ça on touche le fond
sur le plan émotionnel et quoi que je
fasse la personne connaissait tous donc
c'était soit l'un de mes ex soit une
pote soit un ami on comprend que la
personne est près de vous chaque jour
elle vous regardent peut-être dans les
yeux elle vous sourit et après rentrer
chez elle pour écrire tout ça c'est là
qu'on se sent mal à l'aise la personne
est très bien éduqué toutes les virus
sont à leur place tout est parfait un an
qu cois
il est important de parler de
vaccination malgré tout les disputes et
les abonnés perdus
même si c'est une question très sensible
je continuerai d'en parler boudou podium
laura ling
il arrive que des gens soient très
agressif et s'acharne sur mes messages
ou par exemple je parle de la
vaccination contre la grippe en dix ans
pour cette saison il y à tel vaccin
les raisons pour se protéger de la
grippe sont les suivantes je les inhumer
des groupes d'anti vax commence à
reporter mon message incite les gens à
visiter mon profil et à y laisser des
commentaires agressifs
boulet parfois on peut se faire
intimider quand on cherche la justice
dans telle ou telle situation si dès le
début vous utilisez un ton agressif dans
les commentaires ensuite vous re publié
le message est dit que son auteur est la
pire personne au monde et mérite d'être
puni à ce moment là vous devenez la même
source d'intimidation en ligne que celui
qui avait été à l'origine de cette vague
hop hop hop hop on y est dans des cas
comme ça d'abord je ne touche pas aux
commentaires
les gens on écrive encore et encore la
couverture est plus grande
la publication passe dans le top et
après j'enlève la possibilité de
commenter
heureusement sur instagram on peut
fermer les commentaires donc la
publication est dans le top mais je ne
vois pas les commentaires abl estimé m
pour soigner tout le monde à des
impulsions agressive nous sommes des
animaux par nature en tournée dans la
vie réelle je bois pas sur internet dont
la société nous impose des normes de
comportement acceptable
on peut imaginer qu'une femme obèse se
promène dans la rue vous lui dit tu es
une grosse qu tu n'as pas honte de
sortir dehors d'un pool elle vous y
fleurit bien son mari vous donnera une
bonne leçon vente rapide
ja je ne vous vois pas aucune
personnalité connue à qui vous écrivez
des horreurs ne vous voit au fond vous
avez des mains libres vous imaginez on
peut insulter n'importe quelle personne
s en tirer comme ça aucune conséquence
on ne vous trouvera jamais
pas moins les auteurs veulent détruire
la personne éliminée l'élément irritant
sur lequel ils t'ont dans tel ou tel
domaine
le faire disparaître pour toujours de la
médisance
c'est ancré dans la nature humaine nous
voulons absolument parler des uns des
autres
d'un autre côté les gens normaux et
décent ne s'affirme pas au détriment des
autres il ne s'en prendront pas à
quelqu'un d'autre
il ne le blesse rompt pas mais beaucoup
de gens ressentent le besoin d'en
blesser d'autres et à pradines ils sont
persuadés que le dire quelque chose de
méchant on leur fait chaud au coeur
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi elles se transforment en
acteurs parce que c'est leur choix c'est
leur décision et ça n'a rien à voir avec
moi je ne suis que l'objet de leur haine
qu'ils se sont choisis on dépense son
énergie soit sur les gens qu'on aime
soit sur ce qu'on n'aime pas peut-être
qu'ils n'ont personne n'a aimé et que
c'est pourquoi ils dépensent leur
énergie sur - traces trop mignon est-ce
qu'il doit se passer dans la tête d'une
personne pour qu'elle suive quelqu'un
lui crif des insultes
je ne sais pas non plus mais on dit que
ça fait se sentir fort voiture se sentir
dieu il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas
chez later il a quelque chose de cassé
il fait ça pour s'affirmer pour se
rassurer pour expulser son agressivité
ou bien c'est un outil une première un
outil qui sert à attirer l'attention
berné les gens qui écrivent des horreurs
y prennent du plaisir qu'ils éprouvent
une sorte de montée d'adrénaline
si une personne ne se permet pas de
faire certaines choses par exemple elle
voudrait aussi posté ses seins et il a
de quoi
mais comme on l'a visiblement humilié et
les mais contente parce qu'il ne peut
pas le faire alors que moi si d'où la
colère
comment s'en débarrasser elle va écrire
c'est honteux d'être comme ça 40 ans
leur objectif principal est de vous
toucher de faire en sorte que vous les
aperceviez pouvant ce pour que vous
sachiez qu'il ne vous supporte paris pas
drôle les adolescents sont les plus
exposés je suis une adulte mais même moi
j'ai souffert à l'époque
si j'étais une adolescente de 14 ans en
pleine période de puberté et que les
gens m'écrivent et qu'ils me haïssent
nuls m'habite
généralement les adolescents ne savent
pas qui ils sont vraiment et quand une
photo intime devient public
ça touche toujours à la question de
l'estimé de soi à ce qui va se passer
ensuite
ça peut même conduire à des suscite
parce que pour eux c'est la fin du monde
[Musique]
j'ai longtemps été victime ça me déprime
est maintenant j'ignore complètement ce
problème il ne me concerne plus du tout
parce que je suis sous pression
constante je me suis habitué et j'ai
cessé d'y faire attention à un moment
donné on ne ressent que de l'ironie il
est essentiel de relever nos succès nos
qualités et nos talents et si
aujourd'hui on se faisait des louanges à
soi même dans nos stories of medicine
mignonne tags et moi et je vous républi
ray et mon million et demi de followers
verra à quel point vous êtes formidables
nous nous mettons à nous-mêmes
l'étiquette de victimes
maintenant je vois ça comme ça s'il
pleut je peux m'enfermer est resté à la
maison
je peux aussi prendre un parapluie ou je
peux courir sous la pluie sans parapluie
votre combat quand on comprend pourquoi
ils font ça on est plus en colère contre
eux on se dit si ça te soulager de
m'avoir écrit un truc negative equity va
mieux maintenant
vas-y gens souffrent pas moi vous voyez
je ne peux être blessé que par les
doutes quant à mon expertise et
seulement si c'est un expert qui parle
aux pieds si la critique est légitime
je me vexe mais je m'excuse et je refais
tout je le dis je reconnais mon erreur
et je recommence si on compare ça à la
vie réelle c'est comme si on passait
devant une station de métro et qu'un
ivrogne vous insultez vous n'y croyez
pas vous ne cherchez pas à vous
justifiez vous continuez votre chemin
sur internet ça semble différent mais
c'est la même chose en fait tu te
considères tu comme victime de cyber
harcèlement
plus maintenant ça fait quoi d'être
victimes
c'est désagréable peux tu décrire tes
sentiments en quelques mots je me sens
offensé
pognon je ne comprends pas je tente de
dire la vérité
beaucoup de communistes bretons je ne
sais pas tout ce que nous pensions aller
à red si vous êtes tout ici belle
tellement mignonne qui devraient petit
chocolat
si vous me laissez des commentaires
haineux genre beurk
quelle grosse horrible e rei et la dea
dans le travers une salle mâchoire
allez-y continuer ça ne me dérange pas
vraiment non mais si vous me poster de
vraies menaces
vous avez vraiment besoin de consulter
un médecin il faut toujours commencer
par soi même
il n'y a pas de porte sombre qui
ouvrirait sur un endroit sombre qui
cacherait un individu à l'âme sombre et
qui serait le principal agresseur sur le
net russe ou même sur le réseau mondial
ces gens ce sont nous vous deviez pas
moins pouvons faire quelque chose nous
pouvons faire quelque chose avec nous
mêmes pour y remédier
[Musique]
mon
et